[Music]
as Florida and the southeast prepare for
a direct hit from Hurricane Emma
one of the big concerns is the storm
surge that will battle battered coastal
areas forecasters predict the storm
surge could be catastrophic in addition
to the threat that poses to life and
property it also could leave lasting
damage to the coastline dr. Hillary
Stockton is a research oceanographer
with the US Geological Survey she's
looked closely at the impact tropical
weather has had on beach erosion she
joins us from st. Petersburg Florida
good morning dr. Stockton good morning
what is your biggest concern today
well the biggest concern has been the
shifting track it really makes me
worried for my neighbors and community
here in Florida and as an oceanographer
it's studying beach erosion it really
makes me concerned about the beaches in
our state as this large and powerful
storm is going to deliver surge in waves
over potentially very large area we want
to take a look at there's some pictures
actually that we're taking of coastal
areas before and after Hurricane Matthew
last year give us some sense of what
we're looking at well as hurricane
Matthew move up the coast it delivered
really powerful waves and high surge
that started to erode the beaches and
move sand offshore as the beaches eroded
in some places where dunes or buildings
were built on on the sand buildings and
roads were undermined and sometimes
collapse as the waves and surge get even
higher they can inundate a barrier
island and actually cut a breach across
the island severing the communities from
other parts of the island
there's been a construction boom and a
population boom in South Florida in
recent years how does that affect beach
erosion well it affects speech erosion
because in essence it locks that Beach
in place when barrier islands and sandy
beaches want to move and change with
waves and
Curren and that's how they adapt to
changing climates and different sea
levels but when we build on those
islands roads and communities it sort of
locks that Island or beach in place and
it's not allowed to move naturally for
people that look at it and say well this
is just about a beach that you'd be
sitting on it's it's just a beautiful
beach it's much more than that why is it
so important to worry and to be
concerned with some of the erosion that
can take place on these beaches its
beaches really provide the first line of
defense during big storms the beaches
and sand dunes serve to dissipate or
reduce the energy of waves as they
travel up to our communities and they
protect inland areas
dr. Hilary Stockton in st. Petersburg
Florida stay safe you and your family
there in that coastal community thank
you thank you